merci jean pierre
tout d'abord si vous me l'autorisé un
message personnel en introduction je
voudrais remercier une personne qui est
à l'origine
de cette dynamique du grand mouvement
que sont les républicains c'est nicolas
sarkozy je voudrais le remercier ce
matin
je voudrais le remercier parce qu' il se
donne beaucoup de mal ils veillent à
faire en sorte que tous les membres de
la famille et leur place c'est pas si
simple que ça et je voudrais lui dire
comme je voudrais vous dire que personne
ne boude ce matin il y a quelqu'un qui
est françois fillon qui aujourd'hui
soutient notre candidat à la réunion et
il est aussi avec vous aujourd'hui il
est avec nicolas sarkozy cette famille
elle est rassemblée alors merci nicolas
sarkozy
il suffit de suffit de venir remercier
pour qu'ils reviennent alors oui enfin
en tout cas c'était pas arrangé du tour
sera pour la prochaine fois
bien et d'ailleurs pour parler de
nicolas si les socialistes continuent à
reprendre ses idées ça serait une bonne
idée et je vous rappelle que l'idée qui
était la meilleure pour l'emploi c'était
celle qu'ils avaient proposé à l'époque
nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs avec françois
fillon qui était de faire en sorte de
baisser les charges qui pèsent sur le
travail est de faire en sorte
d'augmenter légèrement la tva pour quoi
pour faire un vrai appel d'air de telle
sorte que massivement le coût du travail
pour les entreprises baissent et faire
en sorte que l'emploi reprenne partout
en france pas seulement en ile de france
mais partout sur le territoire français
voilà ce qui était une bonne idée si le
socialiste continue à reprendre les
bonnes idées de la droite et des
républicains c'est bien ils peuvent dès
demain reprendre cette idée je peux vous
dire l'emploi savard décoller
alors
l'un des princes pour l'emploi en ile de
france c'est quoi c'est cette fameuse
taxe sur les bureaux en île de france
c'est quand même stupéfiant la région
ile de france c'est la région qui doit
être doit accomplir ses missions de
moteurs des régions de toutes les
régions de france et en l'occurrence ce
moteur est bien il est handicapé
aujourd'hui les onguents calmin et parce
que les socialistes ont multiplié les
taxes c'est taxe sur les bureaux en île
de france ça fait quoi ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui les grandes entreprises
vont s'installer à londres vont
s'installer à francfort vont s'installer
à genève mais surtout pas à paris ne
crée pas la dynamique est aujourd'hui
l'emploi en île de france par rapport à
toutes les grandes capitales économiques
à travers le monde chut voilà ce que les
socialistes ont réussi à accomplir alors
il est urgent qu'on reprenne les
responsabilités à travers les régions
les 6 et 13 décembre prochain dans
toutes les régions de france pour faire
en sorte de redémarrer l'emploi pour
faire en sorte de redémarrer
l'apprentissage la formation et
particulièrement la formation des
chômeurs de faire en sorte que la
première étape c'est 2015 avec toutes
les régions pour que la deuxième étape
ça soit 2017 avec le candidat des
républicains qui l'emportera et tous
nous hier